So Arlo, Captogen, Autolucil, this is our first GPRC5D-directed CAR-T cell therapy that
is being looked at in clinic already.
So this is a great paper, a presentation that's about to be a paper hopefully soon that Doris
Hansen presented at the last ASH.
And it's just looking at those patients who are quad exposed now.
And this was flat iron and just saying, you know, what are patients getting?
And again, most patients are getting chemotherapy at this point.
There are some patients that have gotten GPRC5D by specifics, as you can tell.
But in majority, these patients don't have a great response or PFS or survival.
13.4 months is what's considered.
Again, these patients had CAR-Ts as well as BCMA by specifics.
But post-BCMA, this is the unmet need in our patient population.
So again, it's a CAR-T autologous against GPRC5D, which we know is on malignant plasma
cells, a little bit different than BCMA that we don't really see it on B cells or, you
know, more premature cells.
And there is a little bit more loss of GPRC5D.
It seems a little bit more like CD19 than it does BCMA.
So this was the phase one study design.
Susan Ball presented this data, I think, last IMS was the most updated.
And then she also presented a poster on patients in the first one to three lines.
So the original study did require three prior lines of therapy.
Patients could have or could not have had BCMA therapy.
So that's sort of how they presented that data in here.
And again, most of these patients, bridging therapy was optional, a little bit over half
PPS.
The patients got it.
And time for infusion was about 19 days from bridging.
Then the results.
So again, response rates were pretty fantastic.
Sorry, my slides didn't show the actual numbers up there.
But 94% overall response rate in those patients that are early line, so one to three prior
lines, 91% to 92% for those who are on late line, greater than three prior lines.
This was at the RP2D dosing, which was considered 150 million cells at the time.
And then CRR in early line has actually been 71%.
Again, median PFS in that early line cohort, again, was presented at IMS was 24.3 months.
And then because of the toxicity.
So most of these toxicities, cytopenias, et cetera, we know how to take care of.
However, GPRC5D, of course, we know there's a specific skin, scusia type stuff.
We see it less compared to the bispecifics and not 100% sure if it's just because it's
not as continuous.
Patients can get it.
But usually if they get it, it goes away after the first.
Two to three months.
And a lot of our patients haven't gotten it.
However, there's a new neurotoxicity.
So we're putting our neurologists, you know, their thinking hats on.
So there's a different toxicity that we see with ataxia.
I forgot what we called it now.
But basically, with the study, we're calling it ONS or other neurotoxic selected OSN, other
selected neurotoxicities.
And again, it's more cerebellum.
And it has to do with maybe GPRC5D being there.
There are some patients with the bispecifics.
You know, maybe one to two years later that I've had that also get this ataxia cerebellar
syndrome.
So definitely very important.
So this was why the next studies have all actually decreased the dose of the cells from
150 to 75.
So all the other data down the road, we'll see what happens at the 75 million cell dose.
And I think that's really important.
We know that relapsed refractory patients, their T cells are different versus early line.
They're very, the microenvironment, the T cells, everything's very, very different.
And maybe cell dosing needs to be different based on when you're treating those patients.
So we'll see.
We'll see if that helps and works out with these studies.
So then there's the quintessential phase two study that is ongoing right now.
And again, most of these patients got 150 million cells.
And there's now a cohort that's getting 75 million, again, just to look at toxicity
versus efficacy.
In the phase one, 75 million and 150 actually did relatively similarly in their both CR
rates as well as overall response rate.
So hopefully we'll have some data soon in the next year.
I'm hoping by 2026.
I don't know yet, but I'm hoping very soon.
And then of course, the ongoing is the phase three study that they have looking at standard
of care versus Arlo cell at the 75 million, that lower dose.
And this is against Darapomdax versus a carfilzomib based regimen as a standard of care.
And again, it started about a year ago and hopefully in the next couple of years, we'll
have some results from earlier line and this does not require BCMA therapy.
So what I forgot to say is a phase two.
It does require prior BCMA therapy.
So that will be in patients who are post BCMA here.
They'll look at patients who have had BCMA versus not.
So here's that development roadmap.
Now with that, just conclusions.
I think it's a really important target in myeloma.
There are other studies being looked at in combination.
I won't talk about that.
I think the next session we'll talk about combinations.
And so again, as a single agent seems to have pretty significant response as well as a toxicity
in general has been pretty significant.
It's pretty easy to take care of these patients, but that neurotox is really important.
And what we have learned, which I can't share yet, but there are some translational data,
hopefully coming soon, the better bridging you have, the less likely these patients get
this.
And so coming back to my usual discussion of bridging therapy for our first line, our
first CAR Ts that have come out, we really need bridging for these patients.
We'll see if the next CAR Ts we don't, and we'll talk about that probably a little bit
later today.
So thank you.